baisse effective du chômage en décembre
près de 80 mille demandeurs d'emploi en
moins optimisme tempéré de martine aubry
le multi récidiviste patrick tissier
condamner tout à l'heure à la perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté de trente
ans pour protéger la société a dit le
procureur de la cour d'assises de
perpignan un nouveau dispositif les
jours de pollution des pastilles vertes
pour les voitures à gaz électrique et
catalyser une taxe sur le gaz oil
enquête dans ce journal au sein de la
brigade financière du palais de justice
de paris des super juge qui remettent
aujourd'hui le rapport à la chancellerie
découverte enfin à ne pas manquer avec
ce personnage tout à fait remarquable
hélène joue avec les loups brahms les
concerts et ses compagnons qu'elle a
apprivoisé madame monsieur bonsoir je
vous le disais en titre pour le
quatrième mois consécutif mais cette
fois-ci de façon significative le
chômage a baissé en france en décembre
optimisme tempéré du côté du
gouvernement il ya un hic le tranchant
pascal golomer moins 2,8 pour cent pour
le mois de décembre
la france comptait à la fin de l'année
dernière 3 millions 27 milles 800
demandeurs d'emploi en tout 12,2 pour
cent de la population active
c'est le quatrième mois consécutif de
baisse les jeunes en sont les principaux
bénéficiaires
le chômage des moins de 25 ans a chuté
de 11% l'an dernier satisfaction du
gouvernement évidemment devant ces bons
résultats mais pas de triomphalisme pour
autant on voit que la tendance de
l'activité positive et bien là ceci dit
c'est le mois de décembre dont je crois
qu'il faut faire très attention
je suis convaincu pour ma part que
beaucoup de ces demandeurs d'emploi au
maintien embauché en travail temporaire
est en contrat à durée déterminée et
qu'on les retrouvera l' agence pour
l'emploi dès le mois prochain
il est vrai qu'en décembre les fêtes de
fin d'année ont généré des emplois des
emplois occasionnels notamment dans le
commerce phénomène difficile à évaluer
et qu'il faut relier à la très bonne
année des entreprises d'intérim un
chiffre d'affaires en hausse dans le
secteur de 21 5% en 97 preuve sans doute
de la reprise économique
c'est aussi le signe de la précarisation
accrue des contrats de travail et ces
chiffres du chômage qui dope le moral du
gouvernement à un moment plutôt
difficile gérard leclerc oui au-delà de
la prudence que réclame toujours les
aléas des statistiques on pourrait même
parler de divine surprise pour un
gouvernement malmené par le mouvement
des chômeurs et shalit et dans le débat
sur les 35 heures les chiffres de
l'emploi confirment l'embellie
économique que l'on percevait depuis
quelques temps avec les records de la
bourse eux les bénéfices confortables de
confortables de grandes entreprises
comme total saint gobain ou alcatel ou
encore le meilleur moral des patrons de
pme
reste une question et une polémique la
question la reprise n'était elle pas
qu'un fétu de paille que balayera la
tempête financière asiatique la
polémique qu'elle redouble sur les 35
heures pour le cnpf ce n'est pas
vraiment le moment de risque et
d'étouffer cette croissance avec un
projet qui va semer l'inquiétude est
déstabilisé des entreprises pour le
gouvernement au contraire l'embellie va
faciliter la négociation dans les
entreprises et nombre de patrons sortir
et déjà leurs calculettes pour
bénéficier des incitations prévues par
le dispositif gouvernemental bref résume
matignon si la croissance continue
si les gens peuvent plus jeunes se
développe si les 35 heures s'applique on
sera au rendez vous d'une baisse
significative du chômage
au second semestre cela fait encore vous
l'admettrez beaucoup de 6 merci car
cette année le recours au travail
intérimaire se développe au point de
toucher tous les secteurs de l'économie
21,5 pour cent de hausse pour 97
un chiffre record qui annonce d'un côté
une reprise de l'économie mais en même
temps qui montre le développement des
emplois précaires et la volonté des
entreprises à jouer la flexibilité
reportage à toulouse christophe la
rocade gilbert usant dans cette
chaudronnerie industrielle de la région
toulousaine l'intérim fait aujourd'hui
partie du quotidien de l'entreprise
jacques of le patron le reconnaît
facilement un quart de ses salariés est
en fait gérés par une agence d'intérim
pour le personnel aussi cela est presque
devenu naturel roland à 25 ans et depuis
deux ans pour lui la terrine c'est un
moyen efficace de gagner sade facilement
du boulot par l'intérim que par l'anpe
j'ai jamais eu jamais cherché par la
levure intérim j'ai toujours eu du
boulot donc car dans certains métiers
spécialisés le travail ne manque pas en
intérim michel lui est intérimaire
depuis 1982 en 16 ans il n'a eu que deux
propositions d'embauché il n'a pas jugé
sérieuse considéré comme un bon
professionnel de mission en mission ils
travaillent quasiment à plein temps mais
pour lui l'intérim est avant tout une
situation qu'il subit
le patronat a tout à y gagner on a pris
fin dans quinze jours
chercher une autre boîte d'intérim comme
ça se passe pour beaucoup aujourd'hui
pour moi c'est pas le cas mais dans la
majorité pauvre pour une grande majorité
d'intérieur pour le gérant de la société
pourtant l'intérim est aujourd'hui
indispensable car pour travailler vite
et au meilleur prix
il faut pouvoir embaucher et débaucher
rapidement aujourd'hui de suite que nous
avons à prendre
nous avons des délais impératifs
ateliers et des grès de +12 trop les
délais pour jacques off c'est la seule
justification de l'intérim
cependant d'autres entrepreneurs
viennent y chercher un autre service
nous avons des choses comme max
compétence qui est ainsi un logiciel de
gestion du personnel que l'on met à
disposition de certaines entreprises
quand ils ont un volume conséquent chine
car les agences d'intérim ont
aujourd'hui une compétence précieuse
pour les entreprises elles savent
trouver des travailleurs confirmé pour
des emplois précaires répéter sans que
l'entreprise ne soient piégés et obligés
d'embaucher patrick tissier
multirécidiviste assassins de la petite
karine a été tout à l'heure condamné à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
assortie d'une période de sûreté de 30
ans l'accusé a écouté le jugement sans
manifester la moindre réaction
reportage à perpignan valérie ermite
bruno girodon la peine maximale pour le
crime le plus odieux qui soit le viol et
le meurtre d'un enfant c'est l'avocat
général qui parle il n'y a pas d'autre
solution dit il que la perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté de trente
ans les jurés l'ont suivi dans son box
blindé à son tour tissier se lève je ne
vous demanderai pas pardon j'aurais trop
peur que ce soit perçu comme un affront
mais je regrette tout le mal que j'ai
fait surtout pour karine je suis le
dernier les derniers un enfant c'est
sacré ce que j'ai fait est impardonnable
est ce qu'il veut pour moi c'est un
inventeur je crois qu'il regrette rien
du tout et des qui si un jour les
relâcher prison il commence à y attend
les mêmes choses et d'autres enfants
d'autres personnes vont mourir dans les
mêmes conditions
la peine de mort c'est fini on ne la
remettra pas mais qui nous le garde pour
préserver les autres enfants et les
autres personnes tissier un monstre de
perversité ou tissier rendu monstrueux
par son enfance et son parcours sommé de
s'expliquer il n'a jamais pu dire le
pourquoi de ces crimes
ses avocats malgré lui ont essayé de le
défendre
si on l'avait soigné plus tôt dès son
adolescence il est vraisemblable que
l'on aurait évité cet enchaînement
effrayant cette horreur à laquelle on a
assisté
je le regrette je le déplore nous avons
tous socialement et de responsabilité
les psychiatres nous disent et sont
unanimes il n'y a rien à faire pour lui
on ne peut pas le soigner
à partir de là la société pour se
défendre
là que moyenne c'est de l'incarcérer de
l'incarcérer définitivement la
perpétuité
patrick tissier s'y attendait il l'avait
écrit à sa mère il n'a eu aucune
réaction à l'énoncé du verdict
pour la troisième fois de son existence
patrick tissier quittant box cour
d'assises pour retourner dans sa prison
dans laquelle il a déjà passé 24 années
de scène une prison où il restera au
minimum jusqu'à l'âge de 70 ans et donc
vraisemblablement il ne sortira jamais
et puis on apprend que le maire de
chablis dans l'yonne un instituteur de
57 ans est écroué pour le viol de
plusieurs enfants
george michael a été mis en examen pour
viol et tentative de viol sur quatre
garçons de 9 à 10 ans élève de l'école
dont il était directeur georges magna
était conseiller général de l'yonne il
est conseiller général pour limiter la
circulation des jours de pollution à
nouveau dispositif devrait prendre place
avec l'utilisation de la pastille verte
qui permettra aux voitures les moins
polluantes de rouler les jours à haut
risque
les véhicules qui porteront ce label
sont d'abord les voitures électriques à
gaz
les voitures catalyser c'est à dire les
dieux
elles vendues après 97 et les voitures à
essence mise en circulation après 93 sur
la sellette le diesel longtemps
considéré comme un carburant inoffensive
désormais une taxation remettrait au
même niveau les voitures à essence et
les voitures roulant au gaz oil d'une
disposition qui concerne de nombreux
automobilistes puisque les voitures
diesel représentent un tiers du parc
automobile français les explications
d'alain aduba ski jean louis serre
depuis 1956 les véhicules qui roulent au
gasoil sont favorisés par rapport à ceux
qui roulent à l'essence
la puissance du moteur diesel est
sous-évaluée de 30%
d'où une vignette moins cher pour une
voiture plus puissant le gouvernement a
décidé de changer cette situation
la vignette augmentera donc pour les
véhicules diesel acheter à partir du 1er
juillet 1998 colère ou scepticisme de
certains automobilistes
mais pour quelle raison parce que
la france fait des très bons turbo
diesel je pense que
on entendra encore moins savez le diesel
il va papa lui plus qu'une naissance les
106 du ce2 et me disais c'est de la
cheville mais mais c'est sa prévu quoi
puisque les sens la vigne est désormais
sera calculé en fonction de deux
nouveaux critères un peu le moteur sera
paulo en gaz carbonique plus la vignette
sera cher 2 à puissance égale les
moteurs diesel seront taxés comme les
moteurs essence chez les distributeurs
automobiles qui avaient misé sur le
diesel c'est la consternation
maintenant la mode c'est le
l'écologie est donc ce qu'on a adoré
hier maintenant c'est presque à renier
complètement et donc forcément nous
serons touchés
en revanche satisfaction de l'industrie
du pétrole qui espère équilibrer les
consommations entre s'emploie gazole
satisfaction également des écologistes
ya actuellement des problèmes de santé
publique due aux émanations des
véhicules diesel notamment des micro
particules qui sont démontrés par tous
les médecins et toutes les études à
partir de ce moment là il n'y a aucune
raison de favoriser ce type de carburant
plus qu'un autre autre menace pour le
diesel une hausse du prix à la pompe
mais dans ce domaine le gouvernement n'a
pas encore tranché ouverture dans les
jours qui viennent du marché du
téléphone à la concurrence la fin du
monopole france télécom avec dans
l'avenir tout un choix pour vos
communications
aujourd'hui l'exemple de cegetel qui
augurait à lyon son service de téléphone
longue distance les explications
nécessaires mais jean-paul chapelle et
de dire encore au bout du fil
les candidats à la baisse des tarifs
téléphoniques un standard spéciale est
désormais à leur disposition cegetel
promet 15 % de réduction sur les
communications longue distance si l'on
compose le 7 à la place du zéro mais
avant de faire les infidélités à france
télécom les nouveaux abonnés veulent
s'assurer qu'ils ont bien tout compris
on n'a plus rien à voir à l'écran télé
challenge et je devais garder votre
abonnement téléphonique actuel pour tous
les appels locaux donc pour les appels
dans votre département
et tous les deux mois vous recevrez une
deuxième facture celle du jeune de
châtellerault 6000 athlètes a beaucoup
en dehors du département monsieur vous
ne ferez pas beaucoup d'économies avec
le thème de fairy tail
pas facile de mettre fin à un siècle de
monopole la concurrence démarre dimanche
pour les habitants de la région
parisienne de rhône alpes et du nord
cent cinquante mille personnes se sont
déjà abonnées aux cette filiale de la
générale des eaux
ce groupe de communication présent dans
le téléphone mobile avec sfr home est
une concurrence acharnée avec france
télécom je crois que l'évolution du
téléphone c'est le téléphone personnel
universal je crois très rapidement on ne
s'intéressera plus à savoir si on
téléphone d'un mobile ou d'une ligne
fixe mais simplement avoir une offre
globale nous serons naturellement je
l'espère les premiers introduire ces
innovations en attendant ces innovations
les accros du téléphone sont une
précieuse clientèle pour qui on
multiplie les promotions l'abonnement de
10 francs par mois leur est offert pour
l'instant leur facture sera en couleurs
avec les appels classés selon leurs
distances mais les nouveaux abonnés
devront continuer à payer leur facture
france télécom qui gardent le monopole
pour tous les appels locaux
un nouveau rapport qui devrait être
remis à la mi février au ministre de
l'éducation estime que plus de 10 % des
heures de cours ne sont pas assurés dans
le secondaire après les paroles très
vive de claude allègre qui dès la
rentrée stigmatisait l'absentéisme des
profs
une étude chiffrée met notamment en
cause la mauvaise organisation des
remplacements jacques devaux et gabriel
camilla le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que le travail de daniel bloch qui
est attendu et son rapport va sûrement
faire plaisir aux enseignants certes il
constate que 10% des heures de cours ne
sont pas assurés
mais la faute est loin d'un incomber aux
profs
l'absentéisme est très marginal il y a
des absents des enseignants comme il ya
100 dans d'autres catégories de
profession les enseignants ne sont pas
plus balade que l'autre un peu tôt bien
nos confrères mais au delà donc de ces
absences tout à fait normal un des
enseignants il y à un dysfonctionnement
du système qui fait que le système
lui-même lui-même génère des absentes et
que en fin de compte donc les programmes
ne sont pas sûres et que les familles ne
sont pas rassurés
ce dysfonctionnement il tient dans la
mise en place des stages dans la
difficulté de remplacer les absences de
courte durée dans l'organisation même de
la vie scolaire
ici au lycée guist'hau a non seulement
2,5 pour cent des cours du mois de
janvier n'ont pas été assurés mais
l'année scolaire s'arrêtera le 12 juin à
cause du bac
je vais avoir neuf cents élèves qui vont
composer dans l'établissement toutes les
salles de classes pourrait être prise
il n'y a que les casses opératoire
pouvoir ils étaient encore une semaine
notre membre des classes de seconde et
de première il ne sera pas possible de
leur mettre en place pour répondre à ces
dysfonctionnements
le rapport préconise notamment de
trouver des solutions en interne que
chaque établissement gère les absences
cours les premières cause d'absence des
enseignants c'est lorsqu'un poste n'est
pas pourvu et ce à la responsabilité
elle en incombe à la rue de grenelle où
dans les rectorats plus de moyens et une
meilleure organisation il restera au
ministre a tiré les enseignements de ce
rapport dans l' affaire elf dumas y at
il une nouvelle affaire dans la sphère
le quotidien le monde parle cet après
midi d'un piratage informatique
intervenu à la brigade financière qui
travaille sur le dossier démentie
aussitôt par la direction de la police
judiciaire le point avec olivier caroff
cette femme
interrogé cet après midi par les
gendarmes c'est la mère de christine
deviers joncour jusqu'à la fin des
années 80 elle tenait la permanence
électorale de roland dumas sa fille elle
aussi proche de l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères aurait perçu une
commission injustifié lors d'une vente
d'armes à taïwan
elle est incarcéré depuis le 7 novembre
dernier or quatre jours plus tard dans
la maison de sa mère
un étrange déménagement nocturne aurait
eu lieu c'est ce qu'ont appris les
gendarmes
en interrogeant le voisinage
j'espère qu'à des arts village met à
l'abri des documents compromettants
aurait-il été mise en lieu sûr si ce que
veulent savoir les enquêteurs
perquisitions à sarlat d'une maison
appartenant à roland dumas puis quelques
mètres plus loin de la résidence d'un
voisin qui aurait confié la clé de sa
cave au président du conseil
constitutionnel
un travail de fourmi qui tranche avec
celui des enquêteurs par ici car à la
brigade financière aujourd'hui il
flottait comme un parfum de suspicion
selon le journal le monde
l'ordinateur de l'un des enquêteurs
chargés de l'affairé elf aurait été
piraté à la veille des perquisitions
menées mardi dernier chez roland dumas
la police judiciaire dément formellement
mais impossible d'oublier qu'en avril 97
la police des polices avait dû enquêter
dans ces mêmes locaux sur un mystérieux
vol de documents et il s'agissait déjà
de l'affairé elf je vous propose
maintenant cette enquête au sein de la
galerie financière du palais de justice
de paris tenus par des super juges qui
se sont regroupées pour rendre leur
travail plus efficace une force de
frappe à travers un nouveau dispositif
consignés dans un rapport remis à la
chancellerie aujourd'hui et que nous
révèle michel fine et jean-louis auxerre
informations en cours ne pas déranger
trois jours après la perquisition chez
roland dumas la juge eva joly travaille
toujours sur l' affaire elf jean pierre
hanotaux dans le dossier de l'arc
il a interrogé puis incarcéré son
président jacques crozemarie jean pierre
hanotaux est chargé aussi de l'énorme
dossier du crédit lyonnais
evelyne picard nice est que les comptes
d'un bureau d'étude du parti communiste
claude nocquet elle a jugé notamment
bernard tapie aujourd'hui ces hommes et
ces femmes qui instruisent des dossiers
d'état travaille seul
demain ils seront entourés de
fonctionnaires des impôts du trésor de
douaniers de comptable un véritable pôle
financier ce qui est important pour
accélérer les procédures pour que ça ne
dure pas trop longtemps
c'est un oeil et exerçait qui est
capable de 10
ah là il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
on ne peut pas forcément dire tout de
suite ce qui ne va pas mais on repère le
poids d'à croche et ça c'est quelque
chose de très important
ces juges qui traque les corrompus
estime il faut aussi changer la loi
selon la corruption est l'un des délits
les plus difficiles à établir notamment
parce qu'elle est prescrite au bout de
trois ans il faut bien voir que dans la
corruption vous n'avez pas de victimes
personnes physiques dans le vol vous
avez quelqu'un qui va se manifester en
disant j'ai été détroussés dans la
corruption
la victime c'est la collectivité locale
c'est l'état donc personne ni à se
manifester et le corrompu comme le
corrupteur sont tes ans et ont intérêt à
rester à rester taisant afin de réformer
la loi il faut avoir les moyens de
l'appliquer pour cela le pool financier
va quitter les vieux couloirs du palais
de justice afin de s'installer dans de
nouveaux locaux de 7000 m² ça va coûter
très cher oui mais la justice financière
est très coûteuse également en termes de
préjudices sociaux
c'est en millions voire en milliards de
nouveaux francs que se situent les
préjudices
alors vous savez quelques millions par
rapport à ça c'est beaucoup par rapport
peut-être au budget de l'état
mais c'est très peu par rapport au
résultat qu'il faut atteindre
curieusement dans ce pool de 300
personnes il n'y aura aucun policier
c'est un peu le paradoxe et les limites
de la réforme à l'étranger en italie le
procureur du parquet de milan requiert
trois ans de prison ferme contre silvio
berlusconi accusé de corruption à
l'égard du fisc a sévi l'émotion est
grande après l'assassinât d'un
conseiller municipal et de son épouse a
battu cette nuit devant leur domicile
rassemblement de plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui ont allumé des bougies en
hommage aux victimes de cet attentat
attribué à lutter à dorothée olliéric
il zappe ou d'ustensiles et de
protestation pour condamner l'attentât
qui a coûté la vie à l'élu sévillan du
parti populaire et à son épouse ou
alberto et asuncion
à l'intérieur de la mairie la famille
des victimes
les amis les collègues et le maire de
séville figé par la même douleur le même
sentiment d'injustice
alberto jimenez et sa femme étaient âgés
tous deux de 37 ans il laisse trois
enfants âgés de 4 à 9 ans pour le chef
du gouvernement ce crime ne restera pas
impuni nous pouvons avoir confiance
personne ne doit douter ils paieront
très cher ce qu'ils ont fait par la loi
mais ils paieront ce double attentat non
revendiqué a été tout de suite
attribuées aux séparatistes basques de
letea le couple a été abattu ici tout
près de la cathédrale de deux balles
tirées à bout portant en sept mois le
thé a assassiné quatre conseillers du
parti populaire ils tuaient au pays
basque
ils ont choisi aujourd'hui la capitale
andalouse pour montrer qu'ils pouvaient
frapper n'importe où en juillet dernier
l'exécution de miguel andré blanco avait
soulevé un immense mouvement de
protestation rien qu'à madrid il
laissait 2 millions dans les rues pour
dire aux terroristes basta ya
ça suffit dans le caucase russe un
français responsable du haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés a été
kidnappés hier soir dans son appartement
pour l'instant aucune rançon n'a été
demandée leurs ambitions c'est ici
devant la porte de son domicile à
quelques centaines de mètres de son
bureau que vincent cochetel a été
kidnappés hier soir par trois hommes
armés et masqués pas de traces de lutte
la voiture du français a même été
retrouvé vide quelques heures plus tard
dans un autre quartier de vladikavkaz la
capitale de l'ossétie du nord dans cette
république comme dans toute la région du
caucase l'enlèvement crapuleux étrangers
contre demande de rançon est devenu une
véritable industrie
on remarque que ce sont de plus en plus
les militaires qui sont pris pour cible
et bon mais assez vrai que ça a des
conséquences sur la façon de travailler
on prend des mesures de sécurité on a un
officier de sécurité en permanence dans
le bureau mais après tout on ne peut pas
être en sécurité
vainqueur sur 24 et là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que en rentrant chez lui le
soir et elle était enlevé parce que on
l'attendait pour l'enlever présent dans
la région depuis 19 mois vincent
cochetel était le dernier français
encore basée dans le caucase chef de la
mission du hcr en ossétie du nord
il était là pour venir en aide aux 220
mille réfugiés qui avaient fui la guerre
en tchétchénie pour les russes cet
enlèvement est une provocation et à
paris le quai d'orsay a rappelé la
position officielle de la france on ne
paye pas de rançon
on a crise irakienne jacques chirac vad
c'est une mise en garde à bagdad contre
je cite les très graves conséquences que
la poursuite de son attitude actuelle
risque d'entraîner si la france comme la
russie continue malgré tout de jouer la
carte diplomatique
ils se joignent désormais américain pour
exiger de saddam hussein qui l'ouvrent
totalement ses portes aux inspecteurs
des nations unies l'enjeu savoir si
l'irak est encore oui ou non un danger
mortel pour ses voisins sans marquer
c'est de leur liberté de travail que
dépend aujourd'hui le risque d'un
nouveau conflit avec saddam hussein ce
sont les inspecteurs des nations unies
les yeux et les oreilles du conseil de
sécurité en irak depuis la fin de la
guerre du golfe
leur mission vérifier sur place que
l'irak a vraiment renoncé à ses armes
toxiques chargé de millions de doses
mortelles chimique ou biologique
dans son dernier rapport le patron les
inspecteurs de l'onu l'australien
richard butler ont plus et comme son
prédécesseur que l'irak avait les moyens
je cite de produire en masse et de
larguer de tels agents biologiques
faux archi faux répond toujours bagdad
oui mais alors pourquoi avec les
inspecteurs de l'onu
les autorités irakiennes joue-t-elle
sans cesse au chat et à la souris et
surtout que dissimule de nombreux
espaces interdits de visite et
curieusement baptisé site présidentiel
en novembre dernier saddam hussein avait
expulsé ces inspecteurs de nationalité
américaine sous l'accusation
d'espionnage
il avait finalement pu revenir à bagdad
après dun nouveau bras de fer et la
médiation de la russie
l'onu avait fait accepté à genève une
meilleure prise en compte de certaines
exigences de l'irak notamment pour les
achats de vivres et de médicaments dont
manque cruellement
la population irakienne mais saddam
hussein n'a pas renvoyé l'ascenseur en
s'obstinant à interdire l'accès des
cycles et présidentielle il fait de
nouveau pesé d'israël aux pays du golfe
une menace inacceptable pour les nations
unies pour la paix et pour son propre
peuple car seuls l'onu peut décider la
fin de l'embargo qui étrangle sa
population depuis sept ans déjà et
l'extrême fermeté de bill clinton face à
l'irak recueille tous les suffrages
américain après le discours du président
sur l'état de l'union
la cote de popularité du bill clinton
atteint un niveau record de 73 % de
satisfaits une remontée spectaculaire
qui touche aussi bien les républicains
que les démocrates ou lendemain de la
visite du pape jean paul ii à cuba c'est
au tour de robert hue de se rendre en
voyage officiel pour la première fois à
laval le secrétaire général du parti
communiste a retrouvé un fidel castro en
treillis fidel castro qui s'expriment
sur l'événement qu'a constitué le
déplacement du saint père à cuba
reportage françoise david
tout semble endormi une heure du matin
dans l'ancien palais du dictateur
batista devenue depuis la révolution le
siège du parti communiste cubain
et pourtant robert hue vient d'être reçu
pendant plus de quatre heures par fidel
castro en tenue militaire
le costume civil réservé à jean paul ii
est déjà remisés au placard on vous un
peu oublié mais vous savez on a
tellement bavarder et cassereau
d'évoquer la visite papale en est bénie
on commence une année de succès mais
même au lendemain de la visite du pape
les affaires pts doivent reprendre
échange de vues sur l'état de leurs
partis respectifs et soit de castro de
rencontre et lionel jospin
robert hue a promis de transmettre
dimanche dernier trois cent mille
fidèles place de la révolution se
pressaient pour assister à la messe de
jean paul ii aujourd'hui nous démonte la
presse que jésus-christ va disparaître
seul le portrait du che demeurera mais
cette brève cohabitation devrait laisser
des marques ou moins dans les esprits
je crois qu'il ya cette émancipation à
travers la la révolution la libération
humaine et puis il ya cette démarche
humaniste de libération également la
travers le fait presque de jésus christ
bien sûr la condamnation par le pape du
blocus américain n'est pas étrangère à
cet engouement subit mais enfin on ne
peut pas parler indéfiniment du
spirituel
il faut aussi aller voir sur le terrain
une plantation de canne à sucre
l'une des seules richesses du pays
quant à la mer des caraïbes le dirigeant
communiste a pu le vérifier
elle est d'un bleu turquoise un vrai
gisement touristique dire à robert hue
autre grand messe celle du régime
cent quarante cinquième anniversaire de
la naissance de rosser martin un des
héros nationaux cubain robert hue et de
la fête
fidel castro n'est pas là mais autour du
communiste français la relève possible
du lider maximo pour une manifestation
révolutionnaire bien sûr robert hue a
été reçu par fidel castro mais il a
également tenu à rencontrer ses
principaux lieutenants des hommes plus
jeunes et moins dogmatique des hommes
qui pensent ils pourraient peut-être
bientôt incarner l'ouverture du parti
communiste cubain et auprès de robert
hue s'est fait en quelque sorte le vrp
de la mutation communiste les assises du
rpr ce week end avant les régionales le
parti consacre sa rénovation lancée par
philippe séguin il ya six mois
à l'ordre du jour notamment l'hypothèse
d'un changement de nom du parti
gaulliste qui pourrait devenir le
rassemblement changer de nom pour
marquer le changement comme l'ont fait
depuis des années tous les partis de
droite
reportage carole comment les militants
du rpr préparent leur grand jour après
six mois difficiles
les assises nationales qui s'ouvre
demain verront la naissance d'un
mouvement gaulliste entièrement rénové
déjà perceptible le changement deviendra
officielle un nouveau projet politique
de nouveaux statuts et même si les
militants le décide
un nouveau nom police a changé six fois
de nom dans son histoire
nous pensons que les nouveaux statuts
que nous venons d'adopter mais surtout
le nouveau projet politique qui va être
soumis aux assises marque un virage
suffisamment important dans l'histoire
de notre mouvement pour qu'il soit
symboliser aussi par un changement de
nom
changer de nom les centristes ont sauté
le pas il y a un peu plus de deux ans le
cds est devenu force démocrate
l'adresse est la même mais les lieux
sont méconnaissables espaces et grandeur
à la mesure de l'ambition de son
président françois bayrou force
démocrate
un nouveau nom censé dynamiser le parti
centriste un nouveau logo pour mieux
afficher ses convictions des étoiles qui
est arc en ciel qui apparaît sur la
gauche de logo et bien c'est l'arc en
ciel comme comme après la pluie c'est
l'arc en ciel européen c'est à dire que
force démocrate portes au coeur de son
projet celui de la construction
européenne depuis six mois l'autre
principale composante de l'udf s'affiche
elle aussi sans complexe démocratie
libérale le nom est explicite
l'emblème un dauphin se veut symbole de
liberté changer de nom et l'adresse
c'est aussi le meilleur moyen de prendre
ses distances avec les affaires l'image
du parti républicain était bienvenue à
un handicap
celle de démocratie libérale est porté
par des hommes nouveau chantre de la
lutte contre la corruption
prenez un ancien juge d'instruction
quand on a poursuivi la sphère de
financement occulte de partis
on a un petit vertige quand on propose
on se voit proposer la place de
trésorier d'un parti politique mais
l'argument de madelin était déterminant
il m'a dit écoute ça fait des années que
tu plaide pour une transparence des
partis je te donne la possibilité
aujourd'hui d'appliquer ce que tu
souhaites fait le conséquences de la
défaite
la droite se rénove rassemblement rpr ou
rpf ce sont les militants gaulliste qui
choisiront ce week end une première
une parenthèse historique à présent en
had il ya tout juste 50 ans gandhi était
assassiné par un fanatique hindou le
père de la nation indienne a laissé
derrière lui un héritage considérable
notamment dans son combat pour les plus
démunis
gérard québec
la procession funéraire de gandhi qui
vient d'être abattu de trois coups de
revolver par un fanatique hindou
ce jour là on a assassiné l'apôtre de la
non-violence le mahatma la grande âme
qui a toujours cherché à se débarrasser
de la servitude terrestre c'est en
combinant le politique et le spirituel
que gandhi s'est montré vraiment
révolutionnaire même s'il ne voulut
jamais remettre en question les formes
traditionnelles de la société indienne
comme la distinction des castes issu
d'une famille de commerçants aisés il
fit ses études de droit en angleterre et
de 20 avocats à londres puis pendant 12
ans gandhi vite en afrique du sud où il
subit les vexations personnel les effets
du racisme de retour en inde gandhi
pratique la résistance passive et il va
réussir à faire porter par tout un
peuple la revendication d'indépendance
jusqu'à lors le parti indien du congrès
se résumait un club d'intellectuels il
va devenir le parti dominant
il reste quand même beaucoup de choses
bien sûr on sait ce qu'ils ne restent
pas il ne reste pas l'idée anti urbaine
en tient dustrit yale d'un gandhi qui
voyait le salut de l'inde dans les
villages
mais à cet égard il reste quand même
depuis le début de l'inde indépendante
une attention portée à la majorité de la
population rurale au delà de cela il
reste surtout le père de la nation
le père de la nation dont on rappelle la
légende dans les moments difficiles
comme aujourd'hui où le parti du congrès
affaiblie et divisée n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui-même pages sportives en
tennis énorme déception pour nicolas
escudé dans le rêve a pris fin
aujourd'hui à melbourne en demi-finale
le china marcello ríos est sorti le
français en trois sets 6 1 6 2 6 3
nicolas escudé reste néanmois le premier
française se qualifier pour les demi
finales des internationaux d'australie
depuis yannick noah il ya huit ans
nicolas escudé s'est dit fatigué a
commis de nombreuses coach avant les
jeux olympiques de nagano préparation à
chamrousse toute la semaine des sportifs
qui ont été sélectionnés comme la jeune
karine ruby 20 ans qui devrait défendre
les couleurs de la france en surf
elle a une grande chance de remporter
une médaille portrait de la femme à
battre christophe tortora et raymond
chape l'art
answer ce sera la terreur des jeux
karine ruby devrait briller à nagano et
s'ils font en coupe du monde font d'elle
la favorite de cette épreuve olympique
difficile pourtant être sûr de soi
lorsque l'on vient d'avoir 20 ans je
attendent beaucoup de moi et j'espère
que j'arriverai à faire plaisir à tous
mais bon c'est pas gagné donc faut voir
à chamrousse la préparation des
sélectionnés n'a pas été de tout repos
le surfeur n'est pas forcément un gentil
rebelles amoureux de poudre aux éleveurs
ont su que c'est un sport qui avis
contraire on s'entraîne tell tale des
athlètes de haut niveau on est reconnu
comme tel on passe six heures sur la
neige par jour en tout cas ces temps ci
voilà on peut pas dire qu'on n'est pas
les athlètes de haut niveau
un vrai sport on vous le répète exigeant
physique et karine l'a bien compris
originaire de la vallée de chamonix
elle est sur le circuit depuis quatre
ans le monde du snowboard n'est pas
encore organisés comme celui de ce qui
faute de moyens pas des clips technique
est là le surf au pied le matin dans les
mains l'après-midi des bricolos gentil
de karine ce sont ses véritables amis
qui en parlent le mieux
je crois karine c'est quelqu'un qui pose
de cerveau au départ qui regarde juste
un petit mot pour pour penser dans
quelques jours karine va donc tenter de
décrocher la première médaille olympique
de l'histoire du surf un sport où les
français glisse vers le succès
je vous emmène maintenant à la
découverte d'un personnage tout à fait
hors du commun
hélène à 28 ans c'est une virtuose se
borner elle se produira ce week-end à
nantes aux folles journées brahms nous a
coûté du piano hélène joue avec les
loups philippe wall street
philippe deslandes
il était une fois un village perdu dans
les bois au nord de new york
il était une fois un chemin qui
partaient des sentiers battus la maison
n'est pas en pain d'épicé pas de
méchantes sorcières ni de princesse
juste une pianiste international rompu
aux lambris des salles de concert ce
regard de loups hélène grimaud la
croisée pour la première fois il ya huit
ans en floride un vétéran du vietnam
aussi passionné de musique que
marginaliser par le voisinage il vivait
avec une louve
l'animal ne se laisser approcher par
personne je sais pas pourquoi vous êtes
plus à l'animal seul qui n'avait pas été
socialisés correctement mais j'ai eu la
chance que rien ne se passe
notre relation s'est développée elle
était plus en plus attachés à moi et
vice versa axel idiotie kai lan il est
là à patxi pas à pattes
hélène a fondé sa propre note rien de
lagaf' plus elle la biologiste de
formation que ces gens qui tentent de
domestiquer les loups de les croiser
avec des chiens social très sophistiquée
et encore une fois très semblable à
celle familiale men et son est toujours
trouvé intéressant ce sont des mots qui
ont été d'une certaine façon plus
persécutée que d'autres ont été éliminés
parce qu'ils étaient en fait le
principal rival de l'homme monia toutes
ces expressions ou le doubs cette image
négative au moyen-âge
l'auteur présente et c'est toujours un
symbole du diable alors qu'en fait ce
sont des animaux qui sont très pacifique
et sondé bien entendu c'est dans leur
intérêt
ils n'étaient pas pacifique aura plus de
mots qui centre au curé il y aurait plus
de survie possible nous aurons serait
beaucoup mieux en groupe que seul
bah
là
le travail gérer et un travail mental
intellectuel d'ailleurs être dans
l'enclos avec les loups c'est très
propice à la concentration silence et en
fait c'est ainsi que je passe la plupart
du temps à travailler ses dehors avec
c'est vrai que à mon avis on ne peut pas
se présenter devant un public sans avoir
été totalement seul avant sinon on
aurait très peu à offrir longtemps
hélène grimaud à chercher un lieu où
poser sa vie et un jour ce fut ici aux
etats unis la nature la liberté la
tolérance tout pour plaire à cet enfant
dont les parents avaient tout tenté pour
canaliser l'esprit rebelle la danse le
karaté est presque en désespoir de cause
le piano me souviens qu'on avait des
amis qui étaient psychologue et bien
toujours vous si vous n'aviez pas à
trouver la musique vous seriez
aujourd'hui une délinquante
à
la dernière note du concerto de brahms
poser les loups se mirent à hurler pur
hasard est parfaite complicité
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres baisse
effective du chômage en décembre près de
80 mille demandeurs d'emploi en moi
optimisme tempéré de martine aubry
le multi récidiviste patrick tissier
qu'on allait tout à l'heure à la
perpétuité assortie d'une peine de
sûreté de trente ans pour protéger la
société a dit le procureur de la cour
d'assises de perpignan un nouveau
dispositif les jours de pollution la
pollution avec des passes hiver pour les
voitures à gaz électrique et catalyser
une taxe sur le gazole dans un instant à
la météo ce side avant puis le point
route valérie maurice 20h55
nestor burma avec guy marchand demain à
7 heures dans thé ou café catherine
ceylac reçoit louis viannet secrétaire
général de la cgt j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver demain soir à 20 heures
merci de votre attention excellente
soirée seront gelés